civiles maniatados ejecutados con
disparos a quemarropa y una gran fosa
común las autoridades denunciaron
quembucha localidad a 40 kilómetros de
kiev que estuvo bajo control ruso hasta
hace poco fueron encontrados 300 cuerpos
50 habrían sido asesinados de forma
extrajudicial según versiones ucranianas
Rusia enfrenta una Nueva Ola de condena
internacional
todos estamos extremadamente
conmocionados y luego es condenado con
la mayor de las fuerzas en segundo lugar
está claro que hay indicios claros de
crímenes de guerra era el ejército ruso
el que estaba en lucha sin embargo para
algunos los nuevos rechazos se tratan
solo de palabras vacías piden mayor
contundencia España
señor presidente macrón Cuántas veces ha
negociado con Vladimir Putin que ha
logrado no se debe dialogar ni negociar
con criminales los criminales deben ser
combatidos
negociaría usted con Hitler claro
Estados Unidos por su parte aseguró que
vendrán más sanciones Y que reunirán
todos los detalles de lo sucedido para
llevarlo a un juicio por crímenes de
guerra
ustedes recordarán que fue criticado por
llamar criminal de guerra a Vladimir
Putin bueno vi lo que pasó en mucha esto
lo justifica es un criminal de Dios
la versión del kremlin es completamente
distinta
por lo que hemos visto las imágenes de
vídeo en muchos aspectos uno no puede
confiar en ellas porque es obvio
nuestros expertos del Ministerio de
defensa han identificado signos de
falsificación los hechos y la cronología
de los eventos tampoco respaldan la
autenticidad de estas alegaciones
el ministro de asuntos exteriores
entregó más detalles sobre el supuesto
montaje
el ejército ruso se retiró por completo
de esta ciudad de 30 de marzo el 31 de
marzo en la alcalde de la ciudad de
lucha declaró soleblemente que todo
estaba en orden cuatro días después
vimos Cómo se organizaban nuestra cuenta
en escena de la calle y como ahora están
tratando de usarla con fines antirrusos
Rusia y Ucrania pidieron revisar el caso
en el consejo de seguridad de las
Naciones Unidas